Merhabalar tedex reset olmak E bu kadar
hoş konuşmacıyı aynı sahneyi
paylaşabiliyor olmak sizlerin
huzurunuzda olmak Müthiş bir heyecan
müthiş bir Onur bana Hayatımda bu anı
yaşattığınız için Hepinize çok teşekkür
ederim önünüzde saygıyla Dior ilk önce
çok
teşekkürler Eee size kısaca Teknoloji
nasıl yapılır diye anlatacağım çok
sıkmaya çalışacağım ama ondan önce daha
önemli bir soru var Aslında bugün
dinlerken onu fark ettim Neden Biz
Teknoloji yapıyoruz Çünkü Zeyneplerin
anlattığı hikayelerden dolayı biz
teknoloji yapmaya çalışıyoruz hayatı
daha iyi kılabilmek için zorlukta
yaşayan insanlara ulaşıp onların
hayatını daha iyi yapabilmek için
teknoloji yapıyoruz asıl Hadise bu
eee size şimdi de kısaca hikayemi
anlatmak istiyorum Hikayemiz Amerika'da
başlıyor 1998 senesi Aralık sonuna doğru
dünyanın O zamanki en meşhur bilim
merkezlerinden biri olan lucent B
laboratuvarlarında genç bir mühendis
Bilişim sektöründe çığır atacak bir
teknoloji üzerinde çalışıyordu tek saç
teli kalı andaki fiber optik kablodan 25
milyon telefon konuşması ve veri aynı
anda geçebilecek bu internet Devriminin
başlaması için gereken
altyapıyı herkes Aralık sonu Noel ve
yılbaşı için evinde ailesiyle beraberken
o mühendis
laboratuvarda yatıp kalkıyordu
laboratuvarı bırakmamıştı Ve nitekim
yılbaşına iki gün kala o sistem
çalışmaya başladı büyük haber oldu
gazetelerde dergilerde şöyle yazıyordu
luen technologist çığır açtı luen takımı
bunu başardı her yerde takım yazıyordu
ama o mühendisin Yani benim ismim hiçbir
yerde Yazmıyordu Peki 3 hafta eve
gitmeden hakikaten eve gitmeden kokarca
gibi laboratuvarda Yatıp kalkıp bu
sistemi hayata kaldıran ben değil miydim
bu teknolojiyi Ben yaratmamış mıydım
Sizce bana haksızlık edilmiyor muydu
aslında edilmiyordu Çünkü bu teknolojiyi
onlarca mühendis binlerce saat Emek
harcayarak yapmıştı ben de onlardan
biriydim ama benim farkım orada olmamın
farkı orada olmak ve bu işi bitirmek
istemem Çünkü benim bir davam vardı bu
da beni 14 yaşıma geri getiriyor 14
yaşında Ailem beni yurt dışına eğitim
almaya yollarken sırt çantama yolda
kullanmak üzere üç tane öğüt verdi
birincisi dediler ki yurt dışına
gidiyorsun ülkeni temsil ediyorsun
sakına taşkınlık yapma 2 yurt dışındasın
yabancısın herkesten en az iki ya da ü
kat daha fazla çalışman lazım
3 yurt dışında eğitimden sonra büyük
baban ülkeye döndüğünde 1926 senesinde
şeker endüstrisini kurdu arkasından Yapı
Kredi Bankasını kurup Türkiye'deki banka
acılığı
modernleştirme Aynı yoldan gitmeye hazır
ol bu sırt çantasını alıp yola çıkıp
eta'da elektronik mıt'de Quantum fizik
nvda teknoloji yönetimi ve B
laboratuvarlarında araştırma yaptıktan
sonra 22 sene sonra ülkeye döndüğümde
yapacağım iş belliydi ülkemde
teknolojinin gelişmesi için destek
vermek gerekirse öncülük
etmekti ve dolaştım son 7 sene içinde
2000'in üzerinde girişimciyle Start upla
beraber oldum 400'ü mentörlük yaptım
Türkiye'de bulunan 50 teknoloji transfer
Ofisi ile beraber çalıştım teknoloji
transfer seminerleri organize ettim
üniversite endüstri platformlarında
bulundum ve şunu fark ettim biz bu
ülkede Teknoloji nasıl gelişir Hatta
teknoloji şirketleri nedir pek
anlamıyoruz size şöyle bir örnek vermek
istiyorum yine geçenlerde bir etkinlik
deyim bir girişimcilik etkinliğinde yim
Eee panelde gayet başarılı olmuş
çoğumuzun gayet iyi tanıdığı Benim de
çok sevdiğim dostlarım var sepet.com lın
yöneticileri e kurucuları değişik
sepetlerim var bizim bu ülkede onlardan
bazıları oradalar ve teknoloji
konuşuyorlar gayet güzel teknoloji
anlatıyorlar Biz Böyle yaptık şöyle
ettik diye ve dayanamadım çoğu zaman
böyle oluyor gidip panelleri dinliyorum
bir yerde de taşkınlık yapmam gerekiyor
hani orada yapamadık burada yapıyoruz
artık e elimi kaldırdım Durun bir dakika
dedim kusura bakmayın dedim ben bel
laboratuvarlarında o Mikron kalaki
fiberin içine o lazer ışınlarını koymak
için Raman efektini kenara attım e
Maxwell denklemlerini Eğdim kuantum
fiziği uyguladım ben buna teknoloji
diyorum Siz öteki tarafta uçak
rezervasyon yazılımı yapıp bana
Teknoloji diye anlatıyorsunuz dedim Hani
o teknolojiye Biz neyiz biz teknoloji
yapmışsak Siz ne yaptınız dedim durdular
e Haklılar da böyle birisini
beklemiyorlardı Eee dediler ki ama
dediler Biz Teknoloji şirketiyiz dediler
Tabii ben onu orada bırakmadım hemen
cevabı yapıştırdım Eğer siz teknoloji
şirketi iseniz Bu sabah beni buraya
getiren taksici Ömer abi de bir
teknoloji şirketi yöneticisi CEO'su
dedim Çünkü arabasında da kullandığı
içten yanmalı motordaki veya
lastiğindeki paten sayısı sizin yemek
rezervasyonu yaptırdığınız yazılımdaki
paten sayısından fazla dedim bir
durdular böyle bir beklemiyorlardı böyle
her gün böyle birileri çıkmıyor Tabii
Eee durdular ve bizi tabii ki o bir
şoför Tamam taksi bizi taksiyle
karşılaştırma dedi bizi uber'le
karşılaştır dedi Uber gibiyiz biz dedi
Biz Teknoloji şirketiyiz dedi Ben dedim
ki Uber mi dedim Uber
Ömer abinin taksisine bir düzgün İş
modeli koyun onu bir iyi arayüzle
bağlayın Alın size über bu kadar
über
sizden biraz daha yani taksici Ömer
abiden biraz daha iyi arayüz yapan biraz
daha veya biraz değil daha çok daha iyi
İş modeli geliştiren O da bir teknoloji
kullanan şirket ama teknoloji şirketi
değil
dedim kaldık orada Belki siz de kaldın
alınız Aslında doğrusu Bir bakıma da en
basit şekilde anlatırsak şöyle bir
tarafta teknoloji yaratan yenilikçi
şirketler var bir tarafta teknoloji
kullanan yenilikçi şirketlerimiz var
Sonuçta ikisi de bir teknoloji
kullanıyor biri teknoloji yaratıp
kullanıyor biri olan teknolojileri
kullanıyor bir kere bunu anlamamız
lazımdı şimdi biraz Tabii akademik
tarafımız olduğumuz için de size biraz
akademik taraftan da yaklaşmam lazım
Bunu da en iyi teknoloji gelişmişlik s
eğrisiyle görüyoruz sağ üst köşede
gördüğünüz teknolojin gelişmiş tarafı
teknoloji gelişmiş bir satürasyon bir
dolgunluğu ulaşmış burada bu
teknolojiler sensörler iot diyoruz
mesela bu iot sensörler yazılımları alıp
bunun üzerine iyi bir iş modeli
koyduğunuzda ve mükemmel bir tasarımla
arayüzle birleştirdiğimizde büyük
kitlelere ulaşabiliyorsunuz sizlere
ulaşabiliyorsunuz Bunlar da Uber Yemek
Sepeti Facebook gibi olup gidip kocaman
şirketler
olabiliyorlar bu tarafta Sol alt köşeye
baktığımızda bilim var ARG var bilim var
tam ortada da teknoloji var Stanford
profesörü Kit devlin der ki teknoloji
bilimin para kazandıran halidir ve bunu
da yapabilmesi için dört tane ana unsur
vardır Birincisi hayatı kolaylaştırması
lazım ikincisi kullanımı çabuk
Bunu en iyi örneklerden bir tanesi iPad
Benim de küçük oğlan var 2 bu5 yaşında
Aynen böyle o Onun resmi değil ama aynı
böyle çalışıyor üçüncüsü bir kere
öğrendikten sonra sürekli eğitim
gerektirmemesi
lazım Bunu da Lütfen okuyun burada bir
mesaj var Bütün erkeklere
burada çünkü anlamıyoruz o işi yani
böyle okumamız gerekiyor orada
dördüncüsü nasıl çalıştığını bilmeden
kullanabilmemiz gerekiyor Okey bütün bu
dört şey çok basit gözükse de altında 7
tane ana unsur var bir ARG ve bilim var
ama burada değişik bilim dallarının
koordine şekilde beraber çalışmaları
gerekiyor teknoloji geliştirmek için tek
bir dalı bilim dalı yetmiyor
ikincisi test
kısmı test yapanlar yani eee teknisyen
ve
Eee teknikerler tarafından Bu sistemin
endüstriyel seviyeye getirilmesi lazım
Nitekim Türkiye'deki en büyük
eksiklerimiz bir tanesi
burada bir sonraki adım tasarım bunu
rahat kullanabilmemiz için tasarımcılar
tarafından planlanması ve tasarlanması
gerekiyor 4ün adım bütün Bu sistemin
Sanayiciler tarafından üretilmesi
gerekiyor ve son adımda biz Bizler
tarafından yani pazara girişte Öncü
kullanıcılar tarafından Beta
versiyonları alınıp denenmesi gerekiyor
İngilizcede buna Pioneer User yani önc
Öncü kullanıcılar ya da early adopter
diyoruz yine erken bu işi alan kişiler
Tabii ki bütün bunun yanında Finans ve
en önemlisi ama en önemlisi bu piyasada
bu ihtiyacı görecek bütün bu oyuncuları
motive edecek bunlara liderlik edecek
kişilere ihtiyacımız var bunlara da
girişimci
diyoruz Türkiye'ye baktığımız zaman ne
görüyoruz Türkiye'ye baktığımız zaman ne
görüyoruz bir iyi taraf Yani bir artı
tarafımız var bir eksi tarafım var bir
iyi haberim var bir kötü haberim var
size hangisiyle
başlayalım Peki iyi haberle başlayalım
iyi haber bütün bu oyuncular var çok
güzel bütün bu saydığım 7 unsur var Ama
bu 7 unsur nasıl beraberler böyleler
tamam mı Herkes başka bir yöne bakıyor
tamam mı Böyle gidiyoruz bilim adamları
beraber çalışmıyor test zaten yapılmıyor
böyle bir test sertifikasyon
süreçlerimiz yok gibi kısaca Şurada
şöyle bir örnek vereyim geçenlerde yine
itü'de müteşekki çocuk geldi sıır zırh
üretmişler bu nişasta gibi yani
İngilizcesi teknolojik terimi non neut
Dynamic kullanıyor Aslında nişasta gibi
parmağınızı yavaş soktuğunuz zaman
geçiyor hızlı bastırdığın zaman duruyor
Nitekim bunu da bir kevlar egne etmişler
Kurşun geldiği zaman
sertleşiyor Birkaç saniye sonra tekrar
yumuşuyor bu dışarıda gördüğümüz
askerler E bu kurşun geçirmez yeleğin
üstüne bir 10 kilo saç da taşımak
zorunda kalmıyorlar mükemmel hemen Bana
geldiler Doğan abi Bu mükemmel bir şey
bunu üretmemiz lazım dedim ki çocuklar
Bunu daha ilk önce test edeceğiz yani
bir tane böyle bir şey yapıp denemiş
siniz poligonda bu iş olmaz yok Biz bunu
üreteceğiz dediler dedim ki çocuklar Bir
dakika durun Bunu kim kullanır dedim
Sizce kim kullanır böyle bir şeyi asker
değil mi polis ve mafya bunun ü
müşterisi var hemen böyle sahaya
çıkmayın arkadaşlar yani Buralar
girilmesi ve sonradan çıkılması zor
yerler Kolay yerler değil tamam yani
hepsinde silah var bazılarında üniforma
var bazılarında üniforma yok ama hepsi
silahlı adamlar yok canım dediler
çıktılar ve birkaç gün sonra neredeyse
ağlayarak geldiler Nitekim Hani
filmlerde görürsünüz belki ama bir abi
bunları almış bir depoya koymuş tutun
Bakayım bunu üstüne Ateş edeceğim demiş
Şimdi
bunlar bu olmuş bu burada oluyor
mahalleleri bilmiyorum ama belki Zeynep
Hanım hangi mahallelerde olur onu
söyleyebilir o isimleri O daha iyi
biliyor galiba ve şöyle oldu dedik ki
evet dedi abi bu test yapmamız lazım ama
Test için Oralarda değil üniversite
içinde bir yerde yapsak baktık
Araştırdık bunu test edecek Türkiye'de
bir yer yok yok Peki nasıl Yaparız
ederiz para da yok dedim ki bir silah
söyleyeyim bana dedim ki onla test
edersek herkes bunu tamam der düşündük
ettik Ben silah konularına pek hakim
değilim dediler ki bunu sizce ne işte
herkesin bildiği maalesef de biliyoruz
diyeceğim yakında inşallah unuturuz bu
tip şeyleri kalaşnikov dediler Evet
Doğan abi bu kalaşnikov lazım bize ama
nasıl bulacağız dediler dedim ki o merak
etmeyin saat 12'den sonra Gazi
mahallesi'de Ben 100 dolara sizi
ayarlarım dedim tamam mı o taraf Tamam
abi Çok iyi bu arada mentörlük böyle
oluyor yani çok bir şey zannetmeyin hani
şu konuşma mentörlük hani bir kota kot
size
söylüyorum ve akabinde Tamam abi bunu
bul sen getir dediler dedim ki hanani bu
kalaşnikov Ben böyle omzuma takacağım bu
iti de oluyor nizamiyeden Biz burada
test yapmaya geldik mi diyeceğiz dedim A
O biraz zor olur dediler Ya 2 sene 3
sene yatarız Tamam abi o zaman onu değil
bizim C4 bomba testlerini yapalım harika
dedim it ünün içine nizamiyeden Biz
cepte bombayla geleceğiz 4 değil 14 sene
yatacağız durdular Nitekim bu Hikaye
Böyle gitti sonunda uçağa uçakla
Amerika'ya gitmek istediler orada hikaye
buydu pet suşisi girmez Ken bu komik
hadiseyi nasıl sokacağız dedik aa doğru
ya o uçağa girmez dediler eee sonunda
İsviçre'de bir laboratuvara gitmek üzere
arabaya kondu o gün dedim ki Arkadaşlar
bunu Beni cep telefonunuzdan silin Çünkü
Türk hapishanelere girersen tanıdık var
Baba tanır eder bir şey halleder Eee
zaten bir sürü tanıdık var orada
Amerika'ya filmlerden gördük biliyoruz
ne yapılır ama Sırp hapishanesinde ne
lisanı bilim ne filmden gördüm lütfen
sizi yolda bu aletle yakalarlarsa
hepimiz İçerideydim beni silin dedim ve
kaldık ve bunu test edemedik Yani bunun
Türkiye'de test ve sertifikasyon yeri
yok nokta Ha var orduda bir yerde var
ama biz ulaşamadık Bir türlü oraya
Nitekim Bütün bunlar var mı var ama
bazıları daha zor var diyelim veya
ulaşamıyoruz Yani bütün bu adımlar
olmazsa belirli teknolojiler buradan
çıkmıyor bunu toparlamak için 5 sene
önce üniversitelerimizde teknoloji
transfer ofisleri yaratıldı teknoloji
transfer ofisleri Bu bahsettiğim 7
unsurun arasında iletişimi sağlamak için
bir arayüz olarak kuruldu ve bunun
koordinasyonunu sağlıyor bu
üniversitelere baktığımız zaman
Bunlardan bazıları bayrağa ele almış
götürüyorlar Ege Üniversitesi Elazığ
Üniversitesi ergs Gaziantep otu ütü
bunların önde gidenleri size daha önce
de söylemiştim değil mi bütün Anadolu'yu
geziyorum ben üniversiteleri geziyorum
oralarda şırı bana Amerika'yı
sorsaydınız her yer anlatırım Avrupa'yı
22 sene kalmışım bilirim ama son
senelerde 7 senede Türkiye'de gördüğüm
heyecanı size anlatamam bilim dalları da
ilerlemeye başladı beraber çalışmaya
başladılar özellikle biyoteknoloji ve
yazılımda güzel hareketler var girişimci
bir öteki problemli noktaydı
jenerasyon lardır bize babalarımız
annelerimiz dedelerimiz başımıza icat
çıkar mı demiş Bunu Hepimiz duyduk Şimdi
de dönüp çıkart diyorlar Yani bu böyle
birdenbire olmuyor yapma yapma kafamıza
vurdular şimdi Hadi bakalım diyorlar
burada da aslında yeniden tek merler iş
gemler kuluçka merkezleri ve
hızlandırıcılar la yollar
açıldı gezdim gördükten sonra fark ettim
ki hani Erzurum'da tırlara yenilikçi
ürün geliştiren Semih müthiş şeyler
yapıyor batıda İstanbul'da kanserli
hücreye kemoterapi ilacını Taşıyıcı
molekülle nokta atışı götürebilen ve bu
sayede vücudun öteki taraflarına zarar
vermeyi sağlayan molekülü sağlayan Rana
hocamız var kuzeyde Trabzon'da oraları
da başka bir dünya onu da bir gün size
anlatırım Ayrıca Eee Trabzon'da beng 737
kokpitin yapmış bir arkadaşımız var
Bunlar Ümit ve Mehmet Kardeşler boing
737 kokpitin sıfırdan yapmışlar buna
uçuş simülasyon yazılımını Bağlamışlar
ve uçuş eğitimi veriyorlar bir hangarın
içinde bu arkadaşlar var doğuda da kalp
tamir kiti üretebilen ve yaratan Mahmut
hocamız var ülkenin her tarafında müthiş
girişimcilerimiz var bu bana müthiş ümit
veriyor Finans tarafı da güzel adımlar
atıyor Özel sektörde risk sermaye
fonları dediğimiz geçen sene sadece
geçen sene 90 teknoloji kullanan
yenilikçi şirkete 20 tane de teknoloji
yaratan yani Fikri mülkiyet patenti olan
şirkete yatırım yaptılar çok mu değil
ama sıfırdan iyi son kısım
tasarımcılarımız biraz daha zor
olduğumuz bir nokta Walter isson der ki
teknolojinin kullanılabilmesi için
Bizler tarafından kabul görmesi için
kalbimizi kazanması lazım der yani
sanatla buluşması lazım der Nitekim
İngilizce Teknolojinin son geldiği
noktaya ne denir zama çoğu zaman fark
etmiyoruz Teknolojinin son bizde
mükemmel teknoloji var dedikleri zaman
İngilizler Amerikalılar şöyle derler
Technology is State of the Art State of
the Art derler sanatla şm teknoloji
derler Teknolojinin son geldiği nokta
sanattır huzur
bulmuştur Bunun için de teknoloji ve
sanatın kesişmesi gerekir Bu kavşakta
baktığımız şu anda baktığımızda sadece
mühendisleri görüyoruz Biz burada beşeri
bilimlerden dil bilimcileri
felsefecileri sosyologları sanatçıları
görmek istiyoruz Lütfen bu teknolojiyle
sanatın kesiştiği kavşağa mühendisleri
benim gibi her şeyi bildiğini zanneden
erkek mühendisleri bırakmayın katastrof
yaratıyorlar felaket ürünler
çıkarıyorlar cevabımız da ne oluyor işte
çalışıyor al kullan oluyor Lütfen burada
kadınlar ve beşeri bilimden sanatçı
ihtiyacımız var Bir sonraki noktamız ise
Sanayi sanayide Aslında biraz da
kırgınım Çünkü 300.000 kalburüstü
diyeceğimiz şirketimizden sadece 300'ü
de Arge merkezi var bu binde biri diyor
sanayinin burada ciddi bir şekilde
konuya el atması lazım son Tabii ki
Demin de bahsettiğim için Sizler Bizler
Öncü kullanıcılar Pioneer User dediğimiz
Öncü kullanıcılar bu teknoloji çıktığı
zaman ve yeni çıkacak Bunlar Beta
versiyon diyoruz bunlara Bizler
tarafından Kullanılıp geri dönüş
verilmesi lazım Peki diyeceksiniz Doğan
Bütün bunların içinde sen ne yapıyorsun
bu kadar oyuncunun içinde benim görevim
ülkedeki teker teker Tüm bu
ekosistemdeki üniversiteleri oyuncuları
bilim adam bilim insanlarını gezip
onların kalbini kazanmak ve bu vizyonu
hepimizin bu işi beraber yapmamız
gerektiğini anlatmak Biz duygusal bir
milletiz kafayı koymadan önce ilk önce
kalben inanmamız
lazım diyeceksiniz ki 4 ondan anlattın 7
bundan anlattın Bir tarafta teknoloji
yaratan bir tarafta teknoloji kullanan
şirketler Trabzon Gaziantep biraz
kafamızı karıştırdın ya Bütün bu
anlatacak anlattıklarını tek bir cümleye
sığdıran bize ya bu ülkede Türkiye'de
teknolojiyi kim yaparı bir cümlede
sıralan diye sorsanız cevabım şu olurdu
Bu ülkede teknolojiyi bu konuya kalbiyle
inanan buna kafa yoran Hatta bu iş için
kafa yemeye hazır olan Bu salonda
oturanlar Bizler Sizler hep beraber
[Alkış]
teşekkürler
i